on the 17th of October 2009 president
Mohamed Nasheed of the Maldives did
something unusual he held this cabinet
meeting underwater he literally took his
ministers scuba diving as it were to
warn the world that his country could
drown unless we control global warming
now I don't know whether he got his
message across the world or not but he
certainly caught my eye I saw a
political stunt you see I'm a politician
and I noticed these things and let's be
honest the Maldives are distant Islands
from where I come from my countries
Bhutan so I didn't lose any sleep over
the impending fate barely two months
later I saw another political stance
this time the prime minister of Nepal he
held his cabinet meeting on Mount
Everest he took all his ministers all
the way up to the base camp of Everest
to warn the world that the Himalayan
glaciers were melting how did that worry
me you bet it did I live in the
Himalayas but did I lose any sleep over
his message no I wasn't ready to let a
political stunt interfere with my beauty
sleep now fast forward 10 years in
February this year I saw this report
this year report basically concludes
that one third of the ice on the Hindu
Kush Himalaya Mountains could melt by
the end of the
sorry but that's only if if we are able
to contain global warming to 1.5 degrees
centigrade over pre-industrial levels
otherwise if we can't the glaciers would
melt much more faster 1.5 degrees
Celsius no way I thought even the Paris
agreements ambitious targets aims to
limit global warming to 2 degrees
centigrade 1.5 degrees centigrade is
what they call the best-case scenario
now this can't be true I thought the
Hindukush himalaya region is the world's
third largest repository of ice after
the North and South Poles that's why we
also called the third Pole there is a
lot of ice in the region and yes the
glaciers they are melting we know that
I've been to those in my country I've
seen them and yes they are melting they
are vulnerable but they can't be that
vulnerable I remember thinking but what
if they are
what if our glaciers melt much more
quickly than I anticipated
what if our glaciers are much more
vulnerable than previously thought and
what if as a result the glacial lakes
now these are lakes that form when
glaciers melt what if those lakes burst
under the weight of additional water and
what if those floods cascade into other
glacial excreting even bigger outbursts
that would create unprecedented flash
floods in my country that would wreck my
country that would wreak havoc in my
country that would have the potential to
literally destroy our land our
livelihood our way of life so that
report caught my attention in ways that
political stunts couldn't it was put
together by the International Center for
integrated Mountain development or ICI
mode which is based in Nepal scientists
and experts
have studied outlicious for decades and
their report kept me awake at night
agonizing about the bad news and what it
meant for my country and my people so
after several sleepless nights I went to
Nepal to visit ec mode
I found a team of highly competent and
dedicated scientists there and here's
what they told me
number one the Hindukush Himalayan
glaciers have been melting for some time
now take that glacier for instance it's
on Mount Everest as you can see this
once massive glacier has already lost
much of its ice number two the glaciers
are now melting much more quickly so
quickly in fact that at just one point
five degree centigrade of global warming
one-third of the glaciers would melt at
two degrees centigrade of global warming
half the glaciers would disappear and if
current trends were to continue a full
two-thirds of our glaciers would vanish
number three global warming means that
our mountains receive more rain and less
snow and unlike snow fall rain melts ice
which just hurts the health of our
glaciers number four pollution in the
region has increased the amount of black
carbon that's deposited on our glaciers
black carbon is like soot black carbon
absorbs heat and just accelerates the
melting of glaciers to summarize our
glaciers are melting rapidly and global
warming is making them melt much more
quickly but what does this mean it means
that the 240 million people who live in
the Hindukush himalaya region in
Afghanistan Pakistan India China Nepal
Bangladesh Myanmar
and my own Beloved Country butanna these
people will be directly affected when
delicious melt when there's more rain
and less snow there will be huge changes
in the way water behaves there'll be
more extremes more intense rain more
flash floods more landslides more
glacial lake outburst floods all this
will cause unimaginable destruction in a
region that already has some of the
poorest people on earth but it's not
just the people in the immediate region
will be affected people living
downstream will also be hit hard
that's because ten of their major rivers
originate in the Hindukush Himalaya
Mountains these rivers provide critical
water for agriculture and drinking water
- more than 1.6 billion people living
downstream that's one in five humans
that's why the Hindukush Himalaya
Mountains are also called the water
towers of Asia but when glaciers melt
when monsoons turn severe those rivers
will obviously flood so they'll be
delicious when water is not required and
droughts will be very common when water
is desperately required in short Asia's
water tower will be broken and that will
be disastrous for one-fifth of humanity
should the rest of the world care should
you for instance care remember I didn't
care when I heard that the Maldives
could disappear under water and that is
the crux of the problem isn't it we
don't care we don't care until we are
personally affected I mean we know we
know climate change is real we know that
we face drastic and dramatic change we
know
that is coming for us yet most of us act
as if everything were normal so we must
care all of us and if you can't care for
those who are affected by the melting of
glaciers you should at least care for
yourself
that's because the Hindukush Himalaya
Mountains the entire region is like the
pulse of the planet if the region falls
sick the entire planet will eventually
suffer and right now with our glaciers
melting rapidly the region is not just
sick it is crying out for health and how
will it affect the rest of the world one
obvious scenario is the potential
destabilization caused by tens of
millions of climate refugees will be
forced to move because they have no or
little water or because their
livelihoods have been destroyed by the
melting of glaciers another scenario we
can't take lightly is the potential of
conflict over water and the political
destabilization in a region that has
three nuclear powers China India
Pakistan I believe that the situation in
our region is grave enough to warrant
the creation of a new intergovernmental
agency so as a native from that part of
the world I want to propose here today
the establishment of the third Pole
Council a high-level intergovernmental
organization tasked with the singular
responsibility of protecting the world's
third largest repository of ice a third
Pole Council would consist of all eight
countries located in the region of
member countries as equal member
countries and could also include reps
organizations and other countries who
have vested interest in the region as
non-voting members but a big idea is to
get all stakeholders together to work
together to work together to monitor the
health of the glaciers to work together
to shape and implement policies to
protect our glaciers and by extension to
protect the billions of people who
depend on a delicious we have to work
together because thinking globally
acting locally does not work we've tried
that in Bhutan we've made immense
sacrifices to act locally and while
individual localized effects efforts
will continue to be important they
cannot stand up to the onslaught of
climate change to stand up to climate
change we must work together we must
think globally and act regionally our
entire region must come together to work
together to fight climate change
together to make our voices heard
together and that includes India and
China they must step up their game they
must take the ownership of the fight to
protect our glaciers and for that these
two countries these two powerful giants
must reduce their own greenhouse gases
control air pollution and lead the fight
lead the global fight against climate
change and all that with a renewed sense
of urgency only then and that too only
may be will our region and other regions
that depend on that licious have any
chance to avoid major catastrophes time
is running out we
act together now otherwise the next time
the PALS cabinet meets on mount everest
that spectacular backdrop may look quite
different and if that happens if our
glaciers melt rising sea levels could
well drown the Maldives and while they
can hold the cabinet meetings underwater
to send an SOS to the world their
country can keep existing only if their
Islands keep existing the Maldives are
still distant away their islands are
distance from where I live but now I pay
close attention to what happens out
there thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]